a true CEO should be operating the
business and so most of the time that
means that they're casting the vision
and they're leading the rest of the
leaders in the business through their
departments I tend to be Project based
so I tend to go really deep on very
meaningful projects that will move a big
thing forward and I'll do that for as
long as it takes L is completely
different than me and we are co-founders
so that's how we divide things up is
I'll go make something really really
valuable and I'll think about how we're
going to Market it and position it and
sell it and then she thinks about
everything else that has to happen in
the business in order to make sure that
happens